Hello, ready? This is Dr. Conner's again. Now we're going to dig into some nutritional considerations and
Understand in the dietary considerations and the nutritional considerations the dietary things are certainly things you can try right away
Certainly these nutritional things you can try right away
But you gotta remember that you got to put it all together. This is is a big web of things and it's you're not just what I want to
Just caution you when we're talking about supplements here. You're not just one supplement away from solving your problems
So just remember that I don't want you to go buy a bunch of stuff and be disappointed
So I do have to talk about this because this is important and to be honest, you know, you could be you know
Just one supplement away of helping your problem. So I don't want to
Underestimated but I don't want to overestimate it. We're not here just to sell a bunch of supplements either
I want you to make the right choices and look at all the different pieces and if you don't attack those triggers
We're going to have very little help and I don't want anybody to take these courses and not feel like it's really helped them
But of course if that could help you at all if you don't client. So let's jump into this
Vitamin D is one of the most essential things with autoimmune disease patients
So why is that because a vitamin D is
Critical to down-regulate the immune response vitamin D is a T reg stimulator
So it stimulates your T reg cells
But in fact, they're showy to study after study that deficiency
Vitamin D actually increases inflammation. So not only does vitamin D help stimulate T regulation cell production
Which helps calm the immune response? So even if a person has
Cancer that wants to stimulate a immune response you want to up-regulate T reg cells. So vitamin D is the thing to take
Of course it has autoimmune disease and an over stimulation of their immune response vitamin D is the thing to take
Because it's going to help stimulate T reg production and help
With balancing the immune response. So it's really really important
component
People ask about how much vitamin D we're going to talk about that in a second
But here's some more studies that correspond specifically to
thyroid issues and more specifically to people with Hashimoto's with
um
TPO antibodies and thyroglobulin antibodies and importance of vitamin D and what it is done to people
Um, and it decreases that expression of the TPO antibodies of the thyroglobulin antibodies and decreasing the
destruction of the thyroid gland itself. So
There's all sorts of what are called genetic polymorphisms or genetic defects
On genetic variants when it comes to vitamin D receptors because vitamin D
Ultimately has to convert to 125d which is the active form of the d that that attaches to the vitamin D receptors on the cells and actually performs its function
Now one of the issues is that a person could have genetic defects or what are called polymorphisms
Uh, the of those vitamin D receptors are they have a
Disrepresentation of those vitamin D receptors on the cell membranes and that can be an issue
This slide explains that a little bit. So vitamin D
Helps immune modulation by upregulating T reg cells balancing B cells
Increasing dendritic cells and macrophages and in thyroid issues with Hashimoto's
They tend to show a greater degree of genetic defects on the vdr receptors
So it affects the vitamin D receptors which allows the body to respond differently to vitamin D
It can affect vitamin D binding protein. It can affect um
Um, other aspects of vitamin D that want alpha and the 25 hydroxy um, which
Which affects the conversion of the circulating vitamin D to the active vitamin D. Now we measure the
the circulating vitamin D to 25 hydroxy when you measure a blood test because it's more balanced
um, and
That's important, but a person can have polymorphisms in that
Conversion factor they could have polymorphism in the receptor itself and we look at these with the genetic test
But really um, really you don't need to so you don't need to do a genetic test to fight out if you have vdr
Issues, no, certainly they'll show in that
But the polymorphisms are have been shown in multiple studies that just about everybody with Hashimoto's has some polymorphisms
And the truth is just about everybody has some polymorphisms in their vitamin D receptors
The right vitamin D receptor genes. Those are the vdr genes
family
So there there could be
polymorphisms in other receptors have to do a cytochrome
P450 pathway that have to do with the conversion factor as well
Many people have those defects remember with genetics that it's not just that you have those defects
It's that that are they expressed and are there other
Epigenetic factors that are affecting that so I'm not recommending that you run out and do our genetic work up to find this out
It's really not essential for this. It's that what they're finding is that
People with Hashimoto's have polymorphisms
But it's really the expression of those polymorphisms that makes the difference and that's what causes issues
What causes those expressions to take place? Well
All these triggers that we've talked about through this entire course are there pathogens like bacteria mold and viruses that
Increasing this increased cytokine response increase inflammatory cytokines
These things will down regulate your vitamin D receptor whether you have a lot of polymorphisms or not
While their automobile response is post-concussion
Other triggers that can cause inflammation anything that's going to upgrade inflammation
It's going to down regulate your your vitamin D receptors and you're in and it's going to
It's going to impair your ability to use vitamin D in your body
gallbladder dysfunction is going to decrease bile release and that's going to cause vitamin D
Balance that now absorb should remember vitamin D A E
And K are all your fat soluble vitamins that need bile
and need healthy bile production by
Phase three in your liver and healthy bile secretion by face or detoxification in your gallbladder in order for you to absorb it
So it's very essential if if you don't have a gallbladder
You need to be taking ox bile with your meals so you have healthy absorption of all your fat soluble vitamins go back to the
uh seven phases of detox book and course for more information on that
And then any sort of intestinal inflammation is going to cause micro vanilla destruction and a lack of
absorption of all your nutrients not just your fat soluble nutrients
weight gain
Lack of sunshine are all going to be factors in your ability to absorb and utilize and vitamin D function on a cellular
receptor
function of each the cell membranes as well
So bottom line is you don't need to run out you get a test for this you don't need to do the genetic test for this
Literally every Hashimoto patient literally every auto immune patient
It's going to have different degrees of a vdr
G defects and their response to vitamin D treatment is going to vary and you're going to have different degrees of
ability to absorb vitamin D as well. So bottom line is every auto immune patient should be on vitamin D
That's just literally the bottom line every auto immune patient needs to be on vitamin D
Now how much did he need to take?
Studies have shown that with auto immune thyroid anywhere between 10,000 and 50,000 I use per day
Are extremely helpful now you want to measure this
So you want to be measuring your vitamin D
Serum levels up to 25 hydroxy that's the stable form that you measure in the blood that's not the active at the cell membrane
But that's a stable form that you'll typically measure in the blood should be anywhere between really
50 to a hundred or maybe even push it 50 to a hundred and 50
That's the levels that you want to maintain
um
Selenium no second supplement that we want to talk about this is a mineral selenium is essential micro nutrient
It's required for many of your metabolic pathways
It forms what are called selenium proteins
And it it's been shown to specifically help with thyroid disorders and Hashimoto's
um
This study showed we conclude that selenium
Um addition to diet may improve inflammatory activity in patients with auto immune thyroid
It is especially those with high activity
So it helps decrease the inflammatory response specifically at the thyroid
Could argue that selenium is good for anybody with any type of
Thyroid issue or any type of auto immune issue
Magnesium probably could have put this second um, but because magnesium is essential in
Well, I think over 600
metabolic pathways in your body it is it is um probably the most
under um
utilized nutrient it is
arguably um
What the majority of people are deficient in this magnesium
Magnesium is a key component to so many metabolic activities
And it has been shown specifically with Hashimoto's and even people with primary hypothyroidism to really
Decrease the inflammatory response at the thyroid itself
Um, then you get into the phases of detoxification. It's a key component for phase um
six uh
In your detoxification process and keeping your problem with regular
T-component everybody should be taking some magnesium
for sure
IP-6 in austisol is something that um you made this maybe completely new to you
So in austitol has been showed in multiple studies to help especially when it's been taken with selenium to help
decrease um
Thyroid antibodies, so it could actually decrease your levels of thyroid antibodies which will help decrease that
immune flare response
fairly inexpensive supplement to take um, it's a good addition to most people's um, supplement protocol
glutathione
Most everybody on this has heard about glutathione. I've talked about glutathione
In many many videos that I've done
We talk about the glutathione pathways with genetics
glutathione is your number one interest cellular detoxification antioxidant
It is you know oxidizing agents in our in our environment from chemicals to pesticides to herbicides to
food products to anything that can cause cellular inflammation
glutathione is the this is the first one to the scene to support the detoxification anti-oxidists
oxidizing affects damaging things that can affect cells that can cause um, cell damage, cell membrane damage
and cancer so your number one cause of cancer is oxidizing agents glutathione is your biggest
Preventer of that
But we talked in previous videos about the oxidizing
oxidizing inflammatory process that's taking place at the thyroid cell itself
Um, and I spoke about it
I think in the last video about it using that's one of the problems with
taking iodide for a thyroid patient. It actually stimulates that oxidization of the thyroid cell
Just cell destruction
And which can lead just to thyroid cancer as well
Glutathione is your best bet against that now through the years glutathione supplements have
really progressed
It used to be back in the day we only gave glutathione we only recommended glutathione
Capsules be opened up and put it a nebulizer and you're nebulized the glutathione that way you put it
In some liquid you dissolve it in the liquid and you stabilize the glutathione that's still a good way of getting glutathione to the lungs
But the reason why we did that is because glutathione supplementation was just so poorly
Absorb I mean you literally got like 5% absorb should rate of what you consumed
Well, then they you know glutathione supplementation progress that
Acicidal glutathione is now really the only thing to take in a pill form
But now we have liposomal glutathione which is a huge game changer your absorb should rate is through the roof on that
You can make some giant changes in people
Helps with detoxification pathways helps with phase one
At phase two liver pathways
And it's I gave you number one
antioxidant detoxifier of the cell huge for decreasing inflammation of the thyroid gland
Black cumin seed is another good thing to decrease inflammation in the thyroid gland
Multiple studies have shown that it decreases TPO antibodies
Um, here's another study that shows that taking black cumin seed for thyroiditis for Hashimoto's
Patients can be very beneficial. That's another possible one to look at
Flavanoids of course we talked about flavanoids throughout this course is so important for
anti-inflammatory response and that's good eGCG from green t-extract
curcumin
Boswellia
mustard
You know just
corset and and it's just just good
Anti-inflammatory properties to decrease inflammation
Not just in the thyroid, but everywhere in your body. So this again is just another oh here's another piece of
One of the flavanoids SOD and catalysis are super beneficial as well
But again, you can see we're just trying to declutter this
this web
And these are just other pieces now. This is a kid is not just this not a protocol
I'm gonna go to buy all these supplements and take these of these are going to be my solution
That could be the very wrong thing to take you have to look at the big picture in the web
You've got to the triggers are really in my point of view your number one thing that you need to look at
That dietary trigger video that we talked about the last one
Probably you're most important and then slowly adding some of these most of these supplements. You probably have it
You're covered. So start looking at those make sure you're not taking any eye and eye though. All right
And we're just continuing on in our study. So stay with me
And it's a process and absorb as much as you possibly can and take notes and know that I'm praying for you
We're gonna work through this together